la manière d'être est un signal je suis
le bruit et la fureur
[Musique]
ceci est une insurrection citoyenne rien
ne sera rentré dans son lit le fleuve
qui est en train de déborder
nous devons
expédié à terre le pouvoir de la droite
qui vous élyséen ces trois là vous allez
craché du sang sera empêchée d'entrer
dans mon local on n'est pas des voyous
on n'est pas du bandit la république se
vend pas encore où je suis à risque iam
very dangerous
les mots ce sont des armes ils peuvent
être des pièges avez vous le sentiment
parfois de vous être laissés griser par
vos paroles dans la reprise et non d'un
grand ennemi des erreurs ça c'est tout à
fait évident des fois des erreurs
d'évaluation parce que je croyais très
bien inspiré de m appeler le bruit et la
fureur
parce que je pensais que les
commentateurs avaient tous l'air en
avant roman est en fait ça s'est
complètement retournée contre moi parce
que les gens sont dit mais ce type i
complètement énervé bon c'est raté bon
ca testa vers de shakespeare après il ya
d'autres fois où c'est pas j'ai été
grisé c'est que tout d'un coup j'ai été
débordé par ce que je ressentais dans la
scène qu'on voit ou jeudi la république
c'est moi dont on a fait des t-shirts
depuis et des plaisanteries
bon cet homme menace de son arme il me
dit monsieur je suis armé il me montre
son petit son petit truc tricolore et à
ce moment là si vous voulez comment nous
expliquer c'est ridicule je sais bien
mais je suis rempli d'une indignation le
terrible parce que je la république
c'est moi c'est pas lui c'est moi qui
suis député qui suis maltraitée à ce
moment là où qui le ressens comme ça bon
voilà alors ça ça a été des moments
mais vous savez je suis pas le premier
dans l'histoire un des modèles
politiques qui ont souvent fait
réfléchir
faucheux densité en d'ancien régime
comme ça ça va un peu mettre du sel dans
l'émission
j'ai été un lecteur très assidu des très
attentif de la biographie de lyons par
paul murray kendall qui a commencé une
magnifique collection chez fayard deux
biographies et le roi lyon ce qui était
un sommet de l'habileté de
l'intelligence politique dit à un moment
donné ma langue n'aura coûté cher je
peux dire que la mienne aussi m'a coûté
cher mais d'autres moments elle a été là
à mon service pour tout d'un coup mettre
plus grand que moi en scène qui étaient
les idées que que j'illustre m et non
bien sûr que c'est pas c'est pas tous
des coûts au butin loin de là je ne vous
imaginait pas vous comparant à nous et
onze lisez la biographie vrai je les lui
il n'y a actuellement
[Musique]